welcome back so where i left off we said
that i was going to throw a ball
and i threw it
at an angle of 45 degrees
to the ground let me draw the ground in
green as hopefully the ground
is that looks more like green water but
i think you you get what i'm saying so i
throw a ball at a 45 degree angle and i
throw it at
what did i say oh no i think it was 10
meters per second
and i want to figure out let's say the
problem is i want to figure out how how
far this ball go or how high does or not
how high well i could figure that out as
well or how long does the ball stay in
the air
and what we said is we can break out
break this vector this vector says you
know has magnitude 10 in the 45 degree
direction
we can break it into its vertical and
horizontal components
so it's horizontal components
this horizontal component would be this
vector and its vertical component would
be this vector
oops i know the other way around it's uh
i always vertical and horizontal are
always the two things that i found most
confusing its vertical component would
be this vector and its horizontal
component would be this vector sorry
sorry for confusing
and so we could treat it just like the
sides of a right triangle because as we
know the vertical is is perpendicular to
the horizontal and what i find very
fascinating about that is that you know
we're dealing with the velocities or and
and and we can still treat them like
they're the sides of a right triangle
and that's why uh that's why vectors in
general are so useful and as we do more
problems if you get more of an intuition
and we said from the the previous
problem that uh we're not the previous
problem the previous presentation that
the length of this side if you just use
your basic trigonometry would be so the
the vertical component
of my velocity
so that's v sub v so v sub vertical
which is an unconventional way to write
it would be 10
sine
of 45 degrees
and that equals what what's sine of 45
degrees the square root of 2 over 2 so
that's 10
times square root of 2 over 2 which
equals 5
square roots
of 2
right
and
the horizontal component of my velocity
is 10 cosine
45 degrees and once a week to figure out
this and this we just use sohcahtoa we
just said that the vertical velocity
over the hypotenuse is equal to the sine
of 45 degrees and then we just
rearranged it to get this and we said
that the horizontal velocity over the
hypotenuse
is equal to the cosine of 45 degrees and
then we solved it to get this we solved
for the horizontal velocity
and then this also equals 5
square roots of 2. so what can we do now
well this is this is what i find to be
the really interesting part if we wanted
to figure out
how
long does the ball stay in the air the
only thing that's keeping the ball from
staying in the air forever is gravity
right gravity is what's what's bringing
the ball back down to the to the ground
and gravity only works in the vertical
direction right
gravity only works i don't like this
color gravity only works in the vertical
direction always pulling directionally
down whoops always pulling directionally
down at 10 meters per second squared
so we can do is we can break this
problem up into two problems we can say
well this ball is going to stay up in
the air
just as long as a ball that was thrown
straight up
as a ball that's thrown straight up with
the same vertical velocity
this ball is going to stay up in the air
for
the same amount of time as something
thrown up straight up
at five squares of two meters per second
and and and what you think about that
because that's actually
at least when i first learned it wasn't
intuitive and the more you think about
it kind of becomes intuitive and then
you might want to experiment it let's
experiment with it
a ball
a ball that's thrown at an angle
will stay up
let's say a ball that's stored in an
angle that gets as high is like let's
say it gets as high as 500 meters
let's say i throw a ball and this is the
motion of the ball the ball
so let's say this is the path of the
ball the ball looks like this right
and let's say the highest point that the
ball traveled
let's say this is 500 meters right that
would be a very that but more like a
cannonball or something
i can't throw a ball 500 meters high so
this is the ball that's actually thrown
at an angle right it travels some
distance along the ground
what i'm saying is that this ball is
going to stay in the ground
it's going to stay in the air the exact
same amount of time
as a ball
that's
that does this
and this is 500 meters
interesting so it doesn't matter what
the horizontal
it doesn't matter what my [ __ ] is the
difference between these two balls and
i'm probably i should probably use
different colors the difference between
this ball which is thrown at a steeper
angle
than this ball which is thrown at kind
of a more it looks almost like a 45
degree angle is that this ball's
horizontal velocity its velocity in this
direction was lower this ball had a much
better horizontal velocity but the time
that they stay in the air and once again
we're assuming nothing about air
resistance or anything the time they
stay in the air is exactly the same
that's really interesting another way to
think about it is if i'm if i'm on a
cliff
and i just drop a ball
and it just goes straight down on a 500
meter cliff
that ball is going to take the same
amount of time to hit the ground it's
going to take the same amount of time to
hit the ground as if the ball
as if another ball that was moving let's
say it was moving it only had horizontal
motion so the second ball goes like this
right so it moves along the horizontal
axis the whole time so it's moving to
the right the whole time while it's
falling but both of these balls let me
draw the second ball in magenta
the second magenta ball is going to take
the same amount of time to hit the
ground and that's because it's vertical
velocity at any given time its velocity
in the downward direction is going to be
the exact same and that's because
gravity is only pulling in the downward
direction i want you to think about that
a lot because that's kind of a core
intuition of vectors and physics is that
you can break out the velocity into
horizontal and vertical components and
that once you do kind of the things that
are affecting it in the vertical
component are identical regardless of
what's happening in the horizontal
so that might have been helpful it might
have confused you further but let's just
continue on with the problem
so let me let me put this a little bit
on the side i took too much space i
might have to so my vertical velocity is
going to be 5 squares of 2 meters per
second
up right and we're going to stay with
the convention positive is up and
negative is down like like just like in
the
coordinate axis so how long is it going
to stay in the air if i throw a ball
straight up at 5 squares of 2 meters per
second how long is it going to stay in
the air well the way i think about it
the easiest way to think about it is the
same amount of time it takes to go up
is the same amount of time it's going to
take it to go down right we learned that
in a couple of videos before
so how long is it going to take it to go
up
well to go up it's going to start at
this speed 5 squares of 2 and then at
the top when it's at the top it's going
to be going it's going to have zero
speed right
it's going to have zero speed so it's
going to decelerate from 5 squares of
two to zero in some amount of time
and here we could just use a very the
very simple equation
change in velocity change in velocity is
equal to acceleration times time well
what's the change in velocities the
final velocity which is 0 right it's the
final velocity 0
minus my initial velocity minus 5 square
roots of 2
is equal to the acceleration that's 10
meters per second squared and forgive me
for not putting the units in right now
because i'm running out of space times
time
so if we solve for t we get you know the
negatives cancel out right the zero
doesn't matter so we get t is equal to
10
over
5 square roots of 2
which equals 2 over the square root of 2
seconds
right t equals 2 over the square root of
2 seconds and of course if we wanted to
rationalize this we could multiply the
top and the bottom by the square root of
2 and you get
well actually you only have to do that
what's 2 divided by the square root of
2. well that's just equal to the square
root of 2 right
because the square root of 2 times
square root of 2 is of course 2. so it
takes a squared of 2 seconds but is that
the total time that the ball's in the
air
no that's the amount of time it takes
for the ball to go to its highest point
it takes square root of two seconds
right to go to its highest point but
it's going to take the exact amount of
time to come back down so the total time
in the air is going to be the total time
of the year and i know i'm doing this
very messy the total time of the year is
2 square roots of 2. just 2 times this
because it takes the same amount of time
to go up as it does to come down and
just it might be confusing but all i did
is i figured out the vertical component
of the velocity using some basic
trigonometry and i said well
it's going to decelerate with gravity
and over that time when it when it's
going up however long it takes it's
going to be going from that initial that
five squares of two meters per second to
zero so how long does it take to
decelerate from five squares of two to
zero given that i'm decelerating with
gravity given that i'm decelerating at
10 meters per second squared it takes us
two squares of two seconds i will
continue this in the next video